From the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.
Today, excuse me, today is Tuesday, July 26, 2011. My name is Joe Manier of the Southern Oil History Program at the University of North Carolina at Chapel Hill.
I'm in Detroit, Michigan with our project, the RFR John Bishop, to do an oil history interview for the Civil Rights History Project,
which is a joint undertaking of the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture and the Library of Congress.
And we're delighted today to be with Dr. William J. Anderson.
Thank you for the welcome and for taking time from your schedule to the panelists.
And thank you for the opportunity of sharing my story, my experiences, if you would, in the Civil Rights Movement. I was privileged to be a part of it.
Well, we're looking forward to the conversation. Absolutely. You were as a child and young man. You were very ambitious and an active young person. You graduated high school, I think, at age 15.
Yes.
And I know that you came up in America, Georgia. And I wonder if you might just sort of get us started here.
They talked a little bit about the world of America's Georgia when you were gone now.
I very often compare the conditions under which I grew up in that amount of the King, Jr.
Because we were barely 170 miles apart. We both experienced the same conditions.
That is, America's was a small farming community with perhaps 5,000, 6,000 people.
And the premier industries, of course, were farming peanuts, cotton, and even some pecans.
And my parents were somewhat educated as compared to others in that my father finished high school. And he started college, more house college, the most prestigious college for black men in the United States probably in the world.
But we don't know whether or not he ever graduated. But that was not important.
The important thing was he went to college, which was probably a single accomplishment within itself, because very, very few blacks, especially males, had the opportunity to go to college.
My mother, who was a high school graduate, and she was teaching school as a high school graduate because she happened to be one of the most educated people in town.
She went back to college after my sister, who was the youngest three children that she had, the youngest started school. Then she went back to college.
And she would go to college in the summer, or in a state by the way, that became historic. But she would go to school in the summer. And she would teach school during the school season.
It took her 20 years, but in that 20 years she got her BS degree, a major, major accomplishment, because we did not know of anyone in the Anderson family who had ever gone that far in college.
So my household anyway was one that recognized the value and the importance of education. And so they stressed that to the three of us, I'd one brother, one sister.
Well, maybe we would have been somewhat hesitant to go ahead and we not had to push, but it was not even a discussion in my home. You're going to college.
We don't care what you study, you can study farming, you can study singing, you can study whatever, but you're going to college.
But the town of America's itself, you could define segregation and discrimination by America's Georgia. There was no such thing as an integration.
The school system was totally separate. You could not have a sandwich in the lunch counter. There were no public transportation vehicles and any kind.
So that was not an issue that were totally segregated facilities, gas stations, what department stores were there that were segregated facilities.
School was totally segregated. So I'm saying that it was almost like two worlds in one, a black world and a white world.
I guess I did not complain that much because I'd not know any better until later on I volunteered to go into the Navy.
But if you look back on it now and you say, well, how could you possibly tolerate those kinds of conditions where you could be walking down the street and the white world would be coming toward you and say, Nigger, get off the sidewalk. You're where I want to walk.
And I would get off the sidewalk and let him have it.
How could you tolerate conditions whereby in your school system anyway, that was an elementary school and high school, but we all recognize we never got a new book.
We always had used books, secondhand books that have been written in and sometimes torn up.
That was a movie house in town, totally segregated again.
The likes had to sit in what we referred to as the buzzard roost up high. You had to go any separate entrance.
So those were the kinds of conditions that existed and were tolerated, if not accepted, certainly not light, but they were tolerated primarily because we did not know any other way.
So as I tried to figure out a way to get out of that situation, so number one, I elected to go to college.
My brother preceded me and he had joined the college. So he had already set the stage, the oldest of the three and he went to college.
Morehouse college also. Don't know whether he ever got a degree on that and that again is not important.
I went to college at Fort Valley State. I was probably attracted there more by having the opportunity to play football than to get a good education. That was secondary.
But somewhere in the back of my mind though, I always wanted to be a doctor. I always wanted to be a doctor. So I knew I had to get a college education if I was going to be a doctor.
So went to Fort Valley for two years and then World War II broke out.
Let me ask before you talk about the war. How did your family afford to send you and your brother to college?
They couldn't. Well, it did not cost like it cost today. This will amaze you. The tuition room and board at Fort Valley State College was $25 a month.
I worked to earning the extra money that I had. I worked as an assistant male carrier. I worked in the in the yard. What was the cafeteria part time?
I was a student and I drove for the president. Let me interject this parenthetically. The president of Fort Valley State College was born. His name was he was the father of Julian Bond, Horace Mann-Bahn, and educator, a renowned educator.
He was writing about education for blacks throughout the South. He selected me to be a driver. Mind you, 16 years old now. I started college at 15, but by 16 I had a license and was driving for the president.
Taking care of his two children. He had a born and a girl. Julian Bond was one of them. But anyway, I did not realize the advantage that I had over millions and millions of other blacks.
I was in the presence of Horace Mann-Bahn, who was one of the premier black educators in the United States. He traveled throughout Georgia, Alabama, Mississippi, studying education for blacks.
I traveled with Horace Mann-Bahn. I drove for him. There was no public transportation. Of course, there was no airplanes. Of course, bus transportation was very limited. So in it place we went, you drove, and I drove for him.
So when the war broke out, though, and I was at home on the weekend, that's America's only about 70 miles from Fort Valley State. When the Japanese attacked Pearl Harbor, the local newspaper, the America's Times Recorder, will never forget, had a front page headline, and they came out with an extra. And you heard them shouting on the streetcorders, I had never heard that in my life.
The Japanese attacked Pearl Harbor. I felt personally attacked. I was living in a society that was totally segregated, discrimination everywhere. I was hated to clans with threatened all of it. But I lived in that environment yet. When the Japanese attacked Pearl Harbor, I felt so they had attacked me personally. They had attacked my family personally.
The next day, I tried to volunteer for the Army. I was 14. My mother stopped it, of course, she said, no, no. So I could not get in. But she waited a year, so when I approached 16, she finally said, he's going to get in the military in one way or the other. And I volunteered for the Navy.
But I did not know what I was volunteering for. It's interesting because I just wanted to get in the military. I would have been a Tuskegee Airman if they'd taken me.
But since I couldn't get to be a Tuskegee Airman, my mother wouldn't sign. I went to a recruiting station, and as I wanted to join, they said, well, we have two branch observers. We have the Army and the Navy.
I had heard about the Army, and I had seen the Army. I had seen them crawling around on the bellies, get shot at, under barbed wire. And I said, I don't want that. Let me have the other one. And they said, oh, there's a Navy. I said, I'll take it.
Then I was told there are two branches of the Navy. There's a Siemens branch, and there's a Stuart's branch. I don't know anything about either one. All I know is, I want to get in the military. I want to get at those Japanese that attacked my home.
So I'll explain it to you. The Stuart's take care of the captain's quarters. They do the cooking. They do the cleaning. I said stop right there. I don't care if the other one is shoveling horse manure. I have not joined in the military to be anybody's servant. I've had that. So I became a Siemens.
Let me take it back for just a minute. Okay. To this feeling you have after in December of 41 after Pro Harbour. It's very interesting to see you're saying you live in a world that's so sharply racially segregated. And if you feel personally engaged by this war question, any reflection on that sense of identification even amidst context that's as difficult as it was.
I equate that to the response of some slaves when they were told the emancipation proclamation has been signed. You're free. They said free to do what?
This is the only home I've ever known. There's the only family I've ever known. Oh, master takes pretty good care of me. I'm not going to leave this freedom.
So as bad as it was in segregation and discrimination and it was horrible, it was the only home that I knew. So yes, I was willing to take up arms to protect a society that wouldn't slave me.
Tell me about any recollections of your time on the service that really stand out maybe in a way that's racially infuctive.
I look back now and knew it was by design. I did not recognize it initially. But my company was the last all black company to go into the United States Navy.
Not a single member of my company that was 75 in my company. Not a single one of them had less than high school education. That was unprecedented. I didn't realize it at the time.
I mean, I was 16 years old. I didn't know about the economic climate, the cultural climate, the educational climate. But as one later on, everyone in my company had not less than a high school education.
We were the most educated company in the United States Navy. We were a test who orchestrated that test. I don't know who planned it, but Secretary of the Navy.
I don't know, but we were a test. My company then excelled because we knew after a while that we were a test. We integrated a battalion, the first black company to integrate a battalion. This was a great leaks.
We excelled again because somehow another our parents had instilled in all of us. You've got to be better. You cannot be just as good as whites. You've got to be better.
Everybody in my company excelled. So I know they had another opportunity when I finished my basic training. I was home only leave and had tons of lightest would you believe today?
I was relieved. I was happy that I missed my tour of duty. And so I was put on private duty. You're going out anywhere. You're going out there to fight the Japanese anyway. So they put me on a ship.
And they made me a part of the seventh fleet under on the Joseph Orman on the Bull Horsley. I went out with the seventh fleet. They stopped in the Philippines for a few days. No, no. In Hawaii and islands for a few days. And then they dropped me off in the Philippines Island down in the late A.G.F.
There I think they forgot about me. The war had just recently come to an end. However, the word had not gotten out to all of these remote islands that the war is over.
So there were Japanese soldiers in the palm trees. And we said that they put them up there with a sack of rice and gave them a gun. And so just stay here and shoot everything that comes near.
So there was still some time in those trees even a year after the war had ended. So when I got out there just before we got off the ship, the captain of the ship said there's a shortage of hospital courmin.
Anyone who has any background at all in medicine report to the deck. I had two years of pre-mad. I reported. He said, okay, we're going to send you to hospital course school.
There were about a half a dozen of us who had a little bit of background at least in pre-mad. And we went to hospital course school for six weeks in the Philippine Islands.
We became doctors in six weeks. We don't know why it takes doctors so long now. But we became doctors in six weeks because hospital courmined worldly primary care physicians of the military.
So for the next year I took care of Sherbus men in the military. I always wore gun, of course. I didn't have to shoot anybody. But everybody out there was armed.
And that experience really confirmed your desire to go forward with medical career.
If they had been ever ined out in my mind as to whether I wanted to be a doctor or not, that would have confirmed it. I enjoyed that to no end.
How did you find your path forward towards medical education?
Now I'm convinced that I want to be a doctor. When I got out of the Navy, I went back to college. I met this wonderful woman that I eventually married.
She said, I was a big man on campus and she was just a lonely freshman. But anyway, I met her and I started to playing for medical school.
In those days, you did not have to have a degree. I finished two years of college in what constituted pre-mad. And I applied to every medical school in the United States and Canada.
I was turned down for several reasons. One Fort Bad Estate college was not recognized. It was not accredited by any accredited agency. None.
It was a very small school. There were 300 students total, not 300 in class, 300 students, 26 boys and all the rest of girls, difficult for boys.
But that was the situation as it was. So I got turned down by all of these colleges.
I was eligible for some GI Bill, two years. But there was a time when you either had to be in school or you would lose some of that credit.
So I moved up to Atlanta with my new wife, who I met Martin Luther King, Jr. And that was prophetic. I did not plan that. He was not Dr. Martin Luther King, Jr. then. He was just Marty.
He was a high school student. He was high school senior. He was graduating the year when up there. And he and my wife's brother were very good friends, very close friends.
Again, prophetic that I would meet the man who would eventually come to the world's leader. When both of us, I was one year older than Martin, we met in Atlanta because I married the right girl.
But while I was waiting now to get into medical school, I had to be in some kind of school. So I went to March your San School of all things.
Because the March your San College curriculum was almost the same as pre-med curriculum for the second and third year. And probably as much as the third and fourth year.
If you can imagine the March your San College having anatomy, physiology, chemistry, pathology, but those were the courses that were being offered. So wow, I said this would prepare me for medical school.
So got that degree and would have stayed in Atlanta to get my college degree except that a federal director or him, federal home owner in Montgomery by the name of Loveless invited me on a mere position in Montgomery.
And he said, if you come here, get your college degree and you can work whenever you want to set your own schedule. I'll pay you $15 a week. Set your own schedule. I could not turn that down.
I went to Montgomery again, prophetic. Who did I meet in Montgomery at Montgomery State College, Ralph David Abinathy.
Not the right Reverend Dr. Ralph David Abinathy, just David Abinathy, schoolmate, and we became very good friends. I think he and my wife were closer than you can imagine because he spent a lot of time at my home while I was working.
I was working at your home, going to school, I'd come home. My wife had fixed him, my dinner, he ate my dinner and she'd have to start all over again.
But he was as close as her brother. He became the Godfather of our oldest child. That's how close we were. So working at the funeral home, I was able to take enough classes that I graduated from Montgomery from Alabama State College. It was called by the way, Alabama State College for Negroes.
Well, people look at me and they have to wonder, you see a Negro or a white. So what we would do as the bus would leave Montgomery going north on one of our tours, we black out the Fronigros on the side of the bus. That was a joke around there.
But anyway, I got my degree from Alabama State College for Negroes and I was offered a job back in Atlanta at the College of Mercury Science.
There, I'm still I'm trying to get into medical school. My eye was on the prize, eyes on the prize. I'm trying to get a medical school. So now I took some graduate studies at Atlanta University working toward a master's.
I was singing in a radio choir at Queen Street Church. One morning, we were broadcasting from this television studio in Atlanta and a local radio station.
WERD, we called it the Good Words station. The program director, Ken Knight, I will never forget him. He called the radio station where I was broadcasting from and said, would you be interested in a career in radio?
Oh no, I'm going to be a doctor. He said in case you change your mind, come back to see me. So one Sunday afternoon, I had nothing else to do, couldn't get in medical school. Then I'm going down to visit this guy in radio.
I went down there and said, would you mind reading a couple of passes this? Okay, I read it. He says, you know, you could do a right radio. I said, all right, I'll try it out. So I became a radio announcer every afternoon for two hours. I was with a guy named Ali Pat, his name was James.
Oh, got his last name now. We call him Ali Pat Patrick, it was his name James Patrick and James Patrick, me still be doing radio in Atlanta.
But there is where I got the experience in radio. The background in in Mercury, Slance at the Mercury, Slance School, why did you do all of those things? You want to be a doctor?
Again, prophetic. When I finally got accepted in medical school and it was only because of a friend of my father, he was a physician practicing in Albany.
Albany, we consider that a sub-rebror of America's with vice-versa, but my dad was an insurance man. I said in his office, wasn't Albany. He was district manager of the North Carolina Mutual Life Insurance Company.
And his office was in Albany and so I would go to Albany on occasion. And he says, why don't you meet my doctor who is a graduate of the Demoan Steel College of osteopathy?
Well, I was curious. And I had that academic curiosity. I want you to know, what is osteopathy? I went to the dictionary and found it had to do with bones.
So I told him, I don't want to do that, daddy. I want to be a real doctor. I want to give shot to little babies, do surgery. I want to be a real doctor.
So finally he convinced me to come, at least meet Dr. Williger Reese. I was respectful of my father. He was a man of small statue, only about 5253.
And I was about 5,000-11, but I never challenged my father. So I went to see, to visit this doctor Reese. He had the biggest practice in town.
He was doing minus surgery. He was delivering babies. He was giving shots. He was writing prescriptions. He said, what that? That's all they ever wanted to do.
He's not trying to tell you that you idiot. He could do that because he was my father. But Williger Reese was doing everything that a black doctor could do in the real South.
Black doctors had no hospital privileges. So Reese happened to be a graduate of what was the Demoan Steel College of osteopathy. It is now Demoan University.
He knew the dean because he had a degree in biochemistry before he went to the College of osteopathy medicine and they needed an instructor in biochemistry.
So they made a deal with him. He had an MD degree that he could not use because it was from a school in New York that lost its accreditation.
So a degree that could not be used, he couldn't get a license. So to see if you come here to teach biochemistry, you can then take courses in osteopathic medicine. You can get a degree in osteopathic medicine.
Now you can get a license. You can practice. Good deal all the way around. So he called a dean and he says, the son of my best friend wants to become a doctor. Will you give him a chance?
Oh, if he's a friend of your best friend, yeah. So I went up to Demoan and this was back in 1952. I took the interest exams on that trip or higher reading comprehension and Minnesota multitasking.
I passed them both and was accepted on the spot. I have never ever looked back. One of the best decisions that had ever been made for me, mind you, for me.
Because osteopathic profession has just, it has grown phenomenally from sixth colleges to now thirty colleges, from fifteen osteopathic physicians to seventy five thousand.
And I had the privilege of becoming the president of the American Hospital Association. So I'm saying, I could never have planned this life out.
Everything along the way, been married to a lady who made me friends with Martin Luther King, Jr.
Winded up in March of his slain school, I learned how to be a mortician that helped me to pay my tuition and get through medical school.
This radio program that got me into the living room, it also helped me to get through medical school because in Demoan, I was a radio announcer and I was a mortician.
I prepared the cadavers for the medical school and I had a radio program that started out. It was what was called the ethnic hour.
One hour, one day a week, they had four segments, Polish, Western, Negro, and something else. And it was losing money.
So I went by the radio station and I told the manager, I needed a job in radio, I had some experience.
Third thing for you, I said, but you've got this one hour program of ethnic music. I said, I can do that program.
He said, it's not making any money. I'll make your offer. I will do the program for free. I will go out and sell the ads.
If it does not make any money, don't pay me. He said, are you nuts? A little bit. A little bit.
Okay, I'll give you a chance. After about two or three months, the program went from one hour, one day a week to four hours every night.
I started his incentives as much time as I wanted. A program that I had labeled Gala time, every night eight to twelve.
I'd get off radio station twelve o'clock. I had called the record back because in those days, the radio announcer was everything. He was radio announcer, he was the engineer, he was the newscaster, he was sportscaster. I did it all. I was the only one in studio.
I would get done about one o'clock, then I would go and study the rest of the night and be ready to go to class the next morning.
The project is to set.
Paul.
We're back after a short break. Dr. Anderson, we were talking about Des Moines and your work, you've been this tremendous success, really transforming this radio hour into a very, very substantial program Gala time.
Could you touch on, could you touch on racial questions inside that framework at all? Did you?
Let's start with when I first, now the interview took place several months before school started, started like in September.
There were social, civic, academic, scholarly organizations on campus. One of them was called the Square and Compass Club, the Masons.
And when I was a student at Alabama State College having little to do, I joined the Masons.
And so I figured a Mason is a Mason.
So when I found out that there was a chapter on campus, I went to join it.
And they said, you can't join. What do you mean? I'm a Mason. Here's my current. I'm a Mason. Do you play Mason?
Yeah, but you came from a clandestine Masonic organization. What do you mean, clandestine? You mean I'm colored? Well, pretty much so.
You don't belong with the real Masons. You're all outside, Joe Mason.
So I did not buck that. I did not challenge that. They had never heard of Martin Luther King Jr. or several movements. So I did not want to get put out of school. So I went along with it.
The other thing that happened was the dean thinking that he was doing something to my benefit said to me, Anderson, this is the morning.
The races do not mix very well here. You're not to date any white women. You're not to socialize with any white women.
That became almost an albatross for me because at one of the official school functions, the chairman of the Bell chemistry department happened to be female, a white female, mind you.
She had a couple of drinks, I think. But something told her to tell one of my classmates to go and get me and bring me to her because she weren't there with me.
Now, what would you do if I dance with her? I'll be put out of school by the dean, the dean's already told me that. If I don't dance with her, I'm going to flink by her chemistry and I'll be put out of school. What a dilemma.
Well, I had another beer and I went in dance with her. Nothing happened. The school didn't collapse. No race for war broke out. I was not put out of school. I was not even calling to the dean's office.
There was a fear that some people had that if there is integration, it would prove to be disastrous. The world would come to an end if white and blikes mix. Nothing happened.
I can say in retrospect that was the beginning of desegregation of the city of the White Iowa. There was a very popular pizza parlour. They are known as babes pizza.
If anybody who had been in the moorin, if they were there as much as 55 or 60 years ago, they knew about babes pizza. A very popular hangout for school kids, college kids, especially from the moorin school college of osteopathy, except that no blacks. They were not served a black.
Did I run into it? Even in Des Moines, I was there for the interview. I stayed at the YMCA. Incidentally, that ingratiated me to the YMCA because the YMCA was one of the few places in the United States that never had segregation.
That is why once I finished medical school and started into practice, I started raising money for the YMCA. Do it till today.
Did the moorin have an active NAACP chapter?
Yes. When you say active, active, but very small and not taken on many projects. There were two or three people who were active in trying to desegregate the city of the moorin.
Did you go to the moorin during Brown vs. Board of Education? That was 54. It was leading up to Brown vs. Board of Education, right?
You were there 52-56. Brown? The Montgomery Bus Boycott?
The Montgomery Bus Boycott was 56. I was graduating. I graduated being 56. We went on though for the entire year, 56 up to 57.
Until smart and we're somewhere 55?
But remember though, word did not travel around as fast as you might expect.
Newspaper articles from Montgomery never got to the moorin. Nobody in the moorin as I knew ever subscribed to the New York Times or the Washington Post.
Television within its infancy, so very rare few people had televisions.
So it was sort of like the emancipation proclamation was signed in January, but they did not find out about it.
In Arkansas until June. The same thing was true pretty much even in 1952.
1956, 1954. Yeah, the schools have been desegregated, but the word didn't get around. The day when it was signed, it did not happen overnight.
Did you have a feeling on leaving Des Moines moving ahead with your life you wanted to Michigan for a year of internship?
Yes.
That you were going to put your hands on this question of trying to change the social realities? Was that in your spirit at that time?
Well, let's prioritize my life.
Sure.
I had an ultimate objective was to become a doctor. And I took a lot of things to become a doctor, including the internship that I got in Flint came about as a result of the same dean, John B. Schumaker, who said the races don't mix.
You are not the socialized with white women in Des Moines. That same dean though after I've been there for three years, fourth year.
I needed to get an internship and Flint, I still had the hospital had one of the best internships in the country.
He personally got on the phone and called administrator Keith Balker will never forget him either. He called him and he says, I've got this colored doctor.
He's a fine student. He's not a troublemaker and he will make a fine intern for you.
This was unprecedented. I had to go out for personal interview before I could get a clinical clerkship there. What if a person interview and the House Fair Training Committee that selects interns call a special meeting just for me?
They interviewed me because they could not challenge my credentials academically because I was in the top 10% of my class.
I was one man there in family practice who says, I don't even know why we're here. I moved that we accept this man as an intern. I was sitting there and never ever done that other people.
I think he put them on the spot because they could not think of a good reason to deny me. They couldn't. I was accepted.
The first black to ever get training outside of a college-owned hospital in history that was 1955 when I went there.
Passing in.
What's up for just a second? We're back after short break. What drew you back to Albany in 1957?
My wife. It was not the lure of going back into this cesspool of segregation and discrimination. I was not going back there to change the world.
Martin Luther King, Jr., was lived known. I knew him personally but in terms of his potential as a world leader was not well known in 1956 and 1957.
We had just come out of the Montgomery bus work cut and all the other places in the south where this might have happened. It's not going to happen here. It happened in Montgomery but it's not going to happen here.
So it was not my intent to go in there and become a rabble rouser and start desegregating Albany. What happened was my wife and I met a couple that were professors at the University of Michigan Flint campus.
We had a good and ginger edwards. Very well educated people. Both PhDs. We became friends. They got to know us very well because they had a couple of young kids and of course we had a couple of young kids. We had three I guess. They had four or they had five.
Anyway, we had some kids and we would get together frequently. We didn't have much money so we didn't go out to clubs or anything like that. We would just go to each other's homes and we'd have dinner and we'd sit around and talk.
I say television was still in this infancy so we would talk. Can you imagine a group of people just sitting around and talking for three or four hours. That's what we did. So they got to know us very well.
Nearing the end of my internship and now I'm in the process of deciding where I'm now to what a practice. In those days that's all you need. Internship you could practice.
There was a group of surgeons at Finosibatic Hospital. D'Aderian was a key one. Slocke of D'Aderian. He and his partner said to me,
we'd like to set you up in practice in Flint. We were fine and she was setting up in practice. His partner was named Taviner. Taviner and D'Aderian.
They said we don't want you to bury yourself and they use those words. Bury yourself in the colored neighborhood. We want you to at least get on a border street because we feel based on our experiences with you.
You're going to have as many white patients as you have black patients. So be prepared to take both. It was a good advice. That's all.
Because in all humility I said I was the best intern and they have a head. But later on they wouldn't give me a residency in surgery.
And that was the bit of, that's the ulterior motive there because they thought I would have a good practice and because they have set me up in practice I would refer my surgery to them.
And I would have. But my wife in one of these conversations with Bird and Ginger Edwards. She says, we're going to go back and talk to Bird and Ginger again.
You want to stay here to practice because you can have a great practice right off from day one. But you made a promise.
What was that? You said if you ever got your education you were going back down south. The rural south where they need you. They don't need you in Flint. I said damn. This woman remembers everything.
And she had women have that phenomenal memory. You know of selective memory. The thing that wants to remember. And just the same way I could tell you every bad thing I've ever done in my life. But she did remember before I even got into medical school.
You said if I ever got my education I was going back.
So we were talking with Bird and Ginger Edwards. They sent me to another room. She talked with me. Go back. Sit Bird and Ginger go back.
So the last time I went to talk to Bird and Ginger they said pack your bag. You're going back.
We're putting Ginger wider. Like like.
Yeah, exceptional. They said you going back. They knew this.
As much as I challenged my wife. I can say in retrospect every major decision I ever made in our entire six or one years of marriage was made by my wife.
The decision to marry her. And just I said I didn't propose to her. She told me what she told one of her college friends when she first met me she said I'm a Mary. I didn't know it.
But it was it was it was that woman who got me to know Martin Luther King which resulted in me ultimately becoming a part of a major civil movement. That's my wife.
What's talking more about her? I want to talk more about her very much.
So against your first instinct you went back to Albany in 1957.
It wasn't exactly to Albany. As a matter of fact I looked around. I did not know for sure where I worked at practice. I thought about my hometown because they had it was segregated but there was a public wing to the hospital.
I was fighting two things being an osteopathic physician which was you and number in Georgia and being black limited my opportunities to get hospital privileges anywhere.
But the need of hospital code wing in America. But in Albany there was no such black patients were put in the basement where they had to compete with the laundry room and the furnishings and the stained pipes.
But then I went to several of the small towns and they all had an interest in having a doctor.
If they were willing to accept the segregated conditions that existed and the other hurdle was getting over you the being an osteopathic physician and they were not well known in those days.
So what prompted me to settle in Albany my father's office was there so he knew everybody in town everybody knew him. So it was not like I had to be introduced.
But the one that convinced me more than anyone else was CB King or 20 CB King. He and I, we had known each other for many years.
My dad was in Albany and I would go down that period and I knew the King family. He had a very outstanding family.
So in his office I remember when he finally convinced me he said to me he called me Andy Andy. All of them will be as good to you as you are to it.
That said to me if I put forth the effort if I give these people good service they take care of me. That made up my mind for me.
And then when a Jorese who was still in practice he was getting somewhat up in age when you got in the middle of 50s it was up in age in those days because I was just barely out of my 20s.
But Bill Reese who was also in practice there said to me you can come in with me if you so desire or if you want to do it on your own I was happy in any way I can to get you started.
Well what else could I want? The lead in lawyer, how to regard it and one of the business doctors in town then it was settled. That's why elected to go to Albany.
Did the practice unfold in those first couple years pretty pretty smooth?
They were standing at my door waiting again and before I get over my doors even I made a mistake actually being pressured by some people who knew I was there to start treating them before I completed an examination.
I had not set up a laboratory didn't do any laboratory tests and I start treating them and I missed a diagnosis of diabetes that I never should have missed if I just been doing my routine.
Of course everybody came in you know got a routine you're the now routine but I'm saying that I was resting the practice but the day it was announced my office was open the office will full all day every day.
I would see as many as a hundred patients a day I never lacked for patients. So if I was doing so well in practice why would I get involved in civil rights? That was not my intent either.
I guess one quick question turned to that. All right. So the stream of patients who came through your door would not have been just from the city of Albany or all around.
Yeah. Okay. So you you would have not not that you didn't know this already but you would have seen in the health circumstances of your patients the reflection of the material conditions.
I was amazed at how inadequate the healthcare was that these people getting. Now there were two black doctors there.
One was had a limited practice by his choosing and Elvin was really joeries who I said was getting up an age some and wanted to cut back some so actually they resulted to go into right doctors even when they didn't want to because that's all had available.
But in doing that they had to go in the back door sit in a separate waiting room and wait until all the white patients had been seen.
Some of the black patients told me stories that were just unimaginable like for example they have several black patients come into office at the same time not in the exam room in the office and they would sit around the table and the doctor was sitting behind his death and what's wrong with you boy and what's wrong with you boy and what's wrong with your girl and make his diagnosis and make out the prescription based on that kind of examination.
Some of these patients in chronic congestive heart failure had to come in once a week to get a shot of mercury hydrant which was a diuretic.
All these people needed was whole leaf digit tell us plain digit tell us it's been around for a hundred years those were the kind of patients that I was seeing when I got there and said I had to hard back to what my wife said these people need you and you don't need to be.
And I but I am saying you don't need to be a major surgeon you just need to be a good old country doctor that listen to the people and give them just basic stuff.
Give them digit tell us give them incident things that they weren't getting.
Some imagine what a difficulty paying.
That's an understatement my office fee was three dollars home calls five dollars when I could get it I never turned anybody down.
I put a lot of money on the books but also I never was hungry.
They would bring me a ham a chicken eggs whether they had I delivered babies for fifty dollars pre-natal that they never got because they never came in delivery postnatal fifty dollars.
In other words I didn't get rich I was never going to get rich fractured down there however I never in hungry I never missed a house note I never missed a car note.
And so when I did get involved in silver rights and they got a little bit ahead of stirring to let you know though when I said to these people follow me to jail a thousand people follow me to jail why.
They did not know what the future would hold they did not know how long they'll be in jail whether get bailed out whether I'm lawyers they went because they trusted their doctor they trusted that doctor I don't think they would have done that it if I had not had that kind of relationship with them so I did alright I was even buying for it automobile eventually bought over this station wagon however they were running to the ground because we ran a.
Carp whore during the breakouts.
I just lost my question.
I'll come back to it in the in the late 50s.
What was did you and your family remember the church?
Oh yeah.
We went to all been we went to my father's church.
He had a church then he had a church in America.
The church in America is a pastor his church in all been it was my Zion.
My Zion Baptist church.
It's pastor was E. James Grant who was about 90 years old then but one of the most courageous men I have ever known.
Courageous in the sense that he would be a pastor on Sundays but he was principal of a school in Baker County during the week.
Baker County had the reputation of being the most racist the most violent county in the end time South.
Bikes were known to go to jail down they had never heard from again.
It had such a terrible reputation that even white people from the South were reluctant to drive through Newton which was in Baker County.
I got on the staff at a small hospital 50 miles away from Albany.
It was down in Bainbridge, Georgia.
A little hospital owned by black doctor 50 beds.
He was a soul doctor only doctor he did everything and he said that if your patients are willing to travel you have privileges right here.
And so I said what privilege do I have?
He said you have a license don't you oh I have a license that's your privilege.
And so the patients of mine who needed to be hospitalized needed some surgery who willing to travel to Bainbridge we would go there but I had to travel through Newton.
And I was a non-violent person mind you but I did have a pistol-pottist permit because I used to make house calls in strange places.
I never knew when the clan was going to decide well doc you've done enough we're going to hang you today.
So I would put a pistol on the seat of my car as I would drive through Newton.
And I said I would accept a ticket if they if I'd stop I would take a ticket but I was not going to jail.
And you hate to take the kind of fatalistic attitude but I was not going to go today because I knew too many people who have been lynched.
I have to be arrested in Newton.
Did you ever did you ever patients come in who had been victims of white violence?
Oh God yes.
Oh yeah.
This was not just a occasional thing this was not in frequent.
Oh no.
As a matter of fact the clan held its rallies one had blocked from my home.
I could go on my backyard and see the flaming cross and see the hood at Clansman and yelling their epithets.
I could hear that they were very close and blacks who would get arrested were very often very frequently beaten up.
As a matter of fact the lawyer himself, C.B. Kane, was going into the jail to visit one of his clients and was beaten by the sheriff himself.
So was it common?
A lawyer yet beaten by the sheriff?
I meant in course after 61 even prior in your first couple of years in Albany.
Did you see people come in as patients?
Not that many.
No that many.
Right.
I want to ask two about the local and the way CP and the criterion club in those years for everything really accelerated.
And the Urban League was there also at the Urban League.
And there were a couple of social clubs because the criterion club was a civic club.
And there was a woman's club called the Utrell, we call it a Utrell, but the Utrell is nature now.
It was like a one of Greek letters but there was some kind of a social club that women belonged to.
And let me say that and there were several neighborhoods that had organizations like the neighborhood that I lived in.
I think we called it the Cedar neighborhood.
Anyway, there were neighborhoods that had names and the women primarily would be organized in these neighborhood groups.
And they would very often petition the city for things like pave industries, put in lights in, put in parks in.
That kind of activity is going on a long time.
And the criterion club, I was a member of the Criterian Club periodically.
We were just going meet with some of the city officials and there were some of the officials that would meet with you.
They wouldn't do anything but they would meet with you.
Ase Kelly was the mayor.
And Ase Kelly was stretching a little bit.
He was probably fairly liberal, fairly liberal, as well as the chief of police, Larry Pritchett.
When I say they were fairly liberal, you could go and sit down and talk with them.
They could not do anything because they were held captive by this system of segregation and discrimination that demanded that they not do anything.
Ase Kelly on occasion had me to come to his office to talk because once the urban movement had been organized, we petitioned the mayor's office to establish a biracial commission.
The mayor had no power to do that.
I'll get to that.
Going back, there were a number of liberal white people that the blacks could talk to.
There was a lady called Miss B. She was the owner, operator of Bob's candy.
She took great pride in the fact that all of her workers were treated the same.
Black and white, the all were treated the same.
That was unheard of in any other business or industry in 1956.
And Miss B, she might still be a lab, she would be 90 or so, but she said very interesting lady.
And there were a few places like that, though, where blacks and whites were equally treated.
I would guess, say, one like Miss B, she and any other emerging liberal-minded whites.
They did not have, may I speak publicly about that today?
No, they couldn't.
Matter of fact, Larry Pritchett at one point, this was at the height of the movement.
He had me in his office.
He was as frustrated as anybody with his hand over his heart, said to me,
Is this the way you think you can make people like you?
And I said to him, Chief, you'll never know whether you can like me or not, as long as you've been kept apart.
This system keeps us apart.
He and I became the best of friends.
When it was over, we became the best of friends.
I want to ask you about that.
I just remember to come back to that point.
I'll tell you what happened to him. Go ahead.
February 1960, in the Greensboro City, and very soon, the wave of cities unfolds across the South.
We start to hear about, well, if the word to reach you, people would have heard a little bit about a group called SNCC.
The momentum is really gathering.
The freedom rise in 61.
It's in 61, October 61, that a few young men from SNCC come down to.
Thank you for coming there.
Do you remember your first sense that something might be checked?
They came to town before October.
They came to town earlier, probably several months earlier, but it was very quiet.
Another way it's all they would do was, they would go to homes and ask them, would you register the boat?
Some of them, fearless ones, or you'll try it, knew they couldn't get it.
But two or three people out of time would go with the SNCC people with an attempt to register the boat.
Of course, they never could get there.
The registrar was always on vacation or taking a 16 hour lunch break.
I do believe they had done away with pole tax at the time, but they had not done away with literally sea tests.
But they would make that so difficult and nobody could pass.
So I'm saying it was just sparsely done like that over period of weeks.
Then, since they weren't making any progress, they started demonstrations.
And they went in the form of no more than three or four with signs, registered the boat, and they'd go downtown, and they would get arrested.
And that began to build.
And I saw that more and more.
And the more they tried to get people registered the more they would get arrested for the least thing.
My office was in a section called Harlem, two blocks out of the heart of town.
Sitting at my desk in my office, I could see these kids going downtown, taking two or three people, and getting arrested.
Getting yelled at, getting cursed.
The black people who were getting registered the boat, being threatened and intimidated,
going to cancel out your mortgage, you're going to lose your job, and I got uncomfortable.
That's going to hit me.
And I said to myself, they're doing that for me.
They are trying to get people registered the boat for me, my family.
So that's when I got out there and joined them.
Tell me your first impressions of Charles Sharad,
or Del Riga?
They were reckless.
They were fearless.
But also in the Criterion Club, when we talk about it, we say, but they had nothing to lose.
They had no jobs, they had no property, they had no money.
Then nothing to lose.
All they had was dedication and commitment.
That's all they had.
As a matter of fact, dying national at one point.
When these people got in these demonstrations, they already had slammed their wheel and
asked to test them.
In other words, if worse came to worse than they were killed, it was not totally unexpected.
But anyway, my conscious was steried, really.
My conscious was steried.
And I said, took it to the Criterion Club first, and I said, we got to do something.
We have to get in front of these kids because we are their leaders to paraphrase Mahatma Gandhi.
So they then said, well, let's don't do it ourselves.
Let's get the other clubs together.
And that's when we call the meeting of the Criterion Club, NAACP, Urban League, the Uralis
Medirins.
And there might have been some other social clubs.
We were called them together at the home of Ed Hamilton, who was a dentist.
He's dead now.
And he was also courageous to open up his home for this meeting, but he knew we were being
watched by the police, by the FBI.
I don't know who else.
But we organized there.
I was elected president, not because I had inexperienced whatsoever.
I had none in several rights.
But I think I was elected because of two things.
Number one, I did not depend on the white people from my living.
I depend on black patients.
Number two, I had not been in all but in long enough to get any enemies among the blacks.
So your ideal, no enemies independent.
And also probably young enough to be...
Young enough to be...
You should be connected to the youth.
Mostly, yeah.
Because any better or with 30, could not be trusted by the youth.
Yeah, just young enough that the youth would follow me.
Yeah.
And that was the beginning.
Can you say that this is very interesting, because obviously one of the key things in this repeats
in every, almost every place that you look at the close of the right history.
Of course there are different opinions and different factions that emerge in a community
and by age, by economic position, et cetera, et cetera, philosophy.
In Albany, can you talk a little bit about the different perspectives and different groups and factions inside the black community,
particularly because there will be tensions, of course, you know, between different folks about how to proceed.
I think we had the extremes.
We had those...
What are you doing?
You're disrupting the peace and tranquility of this.
I'm going to lose my job.
I'm going to lose my house.
Forklose my mortgage.
And they stayed as far away from it as they could.
They never came to the intermediaries, no mass meetings, anything else.
That was at one extreme.
At the other extreme, there were those who were willing to throw caution to the wind as the past or mountain Zion.
I'm saying here's a man who depended on white races in Bechalca, California, living,
yet he would open up his church for the mass meetings.
Those are the extreme.
There were some of those in the middle now that would give money.
They weren't about to know it.
That would be those who would come to the mass meetings, but they're not going to get in the march in demonstration.
So I'm saying that you have them all across the spectrums.
Go for it. Go for it. I'm with you.
But I'm not going to get in the way.
I'm not going to miss the meeting.
But I want to slipy-fired all of us.
So I'm saying I don't believe there was a single black there that was untouched.
But you have the extremes of yes and touch.
But I'm not going to do anything about it.
Either I'm afraid to, or I'm reluctant to.
I don't want you to disturb me.
I'm doing all right.
Or the others, I say, who?
We going all the way.
Now, I do believe there was a pent-up desire for freedom by many blacks.
But they didn't like it, but had no way to get out of it.
And it was not until Martin Luther King came along that they realized there is a way other than what has been the historic way of something differences.
Harking back to the Revolutionary War, the Spanish-American War, we've always settled our differences by wars.
And that was a mindset of people.
We can't beat them because we don't have the guns and whatnot.
So we'd be just better learning how to live with it.
But then Martin Luther King came along with this new armamentarian, and it was peace and non-violence.
And the fact that it was successful there, these people felt it can't happen here.
And would you believe they looked at me to be that Martin Luther King for all many?
No, no, no, no, no.
So after we finally got the organization together and I was elected president, and the name just emerged.
And everybody came and said, well, let's have a whole list of names choose from.
In conversation, somebody said, well, let's call it a movement.
And that's how the name happened.
All been a movement.
Then I think I said, but none of us have inexperience in this, but I know somebody who does.
And now that marriage, meet Martin Luther King, that job in Montgomery, meet and have Evan Athe.
These are people now that I could get on and call personally, personally.
Now there was some reluctant to bring them in.
Let me say that.
There was some reluctance because SNCC and NAACP depended on the drama of the hour to build up their coffers,
because they brought in more money as there was that.
So we decided then we made certain that Martin Luther King and Evan Athe did not come in with the full SNCC organization and take over the ordinary.
SCLC.
SCLC, right? Where did I say SCLC?
SNCC, not come in and take over.
Well, SNCC wanted to make sure that SCLC didn't come and take over.
So then we agreed, okay, he'll come under those conditions.
So because my wife and I knew Martin were out well enough that we could call them and ask them to come and let them know what the situation was.
So they came down our invitation and they came to a church rally and this was that...
Bewerb Baptist church. Bewerb.
I think they were in the church.
Shallow. Shallow. Shallow was the first one. They came to Shallow.
How the word got out all those Southwest Georgia, Joe, I will never know.
There was no radio, no television, no newspapers and many places.
They didn't have electric lights.
But the word spread throughout South Georgia and literally thousands of people came to that mass reading that night.
We filled up both churches. Shallow and Mount Zanglet right across the street from each other.
Martin came there, not with an unterraged.
He came there with Andy Young, White Walker and Evanathy.
I believe that was it, the first trip.
Because his intent was to speak out of rally and go back to Atlanta.
So he spoke at Shallow and he was going to see that you have to go across the street to Mount Zion.
And he did. And he was going to see there, of course within his ear, you got to go back to Shallow.
I mean, yeah, to Shallow.
And he says, I've done that. And he told me how tired it was.
I said, but these people have been waiting 100 years for you.
And they could not get in these two churches. That's whether in the empty doubt they filled up again.
He spoke four times that one night.
And my observation was every time he spoke, he got stronger.
And Evanathy was a great warm up man.
You go to these theatrical producers, as always, the warm up act that come before the main act.
Evanathy was great at that.
Then Martin would come on and mesmerize the people.
So he did that with no intentions of staying.
But when he spoke, huh?
Except when he spoke the last time.
I said to 1000 people here, Martin Luther King is committed to Albany, the Albany Movement.
And he's going to come back and be with us throughout.
And the young has reported on numerous occasions, I tricked Martin in the coming down there to give a speech.
And they committed him to stay.
And I say guilty.
I don't deny it was not intended to be trickery.
But I had not talked with him about whether he would do it or not.
But I saw. I saw in him a stride toward freedom was being made because I saw how the people.
They picked him up and carried him on.
Yes, he was kind of tired when he got there.
But the more he spoke, the stronger he got.
And he saw these people already.
And Martin could not have done any of this without the people.
We all knew that.
The people had to be ready.
So the next day.
And the next day he went back to Atlanta.
But then we started having mass meetings every night.
We would have board meetings. We had a board.
Slater King was the vice president.
Marion Page was Secretary Treasurer.
Goldie Jackson was the secretary.
Bo Jackson was the treasurer.
We had a board.
And we met every night, if you can imagine.
This mass meetings were going some time to ten left for the pocket of late.
And then we were going to have mass meetings for a couple of hours after that.
And then I would try to practice.
I'm also about 25 or 30 pounds over a period of about six, eight months.
Were you also feeling picked up and carried on?
Absolutely.
If you don't get emotional involved, you're not going to take those kind of risks here.
Don't let anybody tell you that I can intellectually sit here and decide I'm going to go into the fire.
I'm going to face down the Ku Kerk's clan.
You don't do that at an intellectual level.
It's done. It's acted out at the emotional level.
Yes. And all of us got emotional involved.
And when I can get up in church and say, OK, we go into jail.
And 500 people get behind me.
You know they didn't sit on think about that.
They didn't go home and figure out who's going to pay the bills while I'm going.
Well, I still have my job. No, no, no.
The people were ready for freedom.
They had been enslaved, literally enslaved, emotionally enslaved economically.
They had been enslaved for so many years.
They were ready for this change.
The time was right.
Let's talk a little bit about the arrests and going to jail.
Which time?
I'm thinking that first time.
You mean Reverend King and Dr. King and Reverend Edward Apples?
Well, that was not the first time.
The first time.
It was not me again. It was my wife.
We had had a rally every night leading up to a Sunday night.
And we announced at the Sunday night, we even had a round of Sunday night on Sunday night.
We said those who are ready to go to jail, we'll meet here Monday morning,
7 o'clock, ready to go to jail.
At breakfast that morning at home and I had three children then.
And I said to my children, before this is over, it is very likely that your father is going to be in jail.
I want you to know, I'm going to jail, not for anything. I'm done wrong.
I have not heard anybody. I have not stolen. I'm killing anybody.
None of the like thing like that. I'm going to jail for your rights. I'm going to jail.
But we have the right to vote.
Whether they understood it or not, I think they came to appreciate it quite a bit later.
So the next morning, my wife and I, together,
my little king and Abbot, that's when they're there then, that was just us.
We led this group of a couple of hundred people, crazy enough to follow us downtown.
We walked around what we called the town square, right in front of the courthouse, right in front of the jail,
all around the block. Nothing happened.
Did it a second time? Nothing happened.
I said to my wife, honey, nothing going to happen today.
I'm going to my office. You take them around one more time and then go back to the church.
So I peeled off with them all, just two blocks away.
That third time around, they were waiting, locked up every one of them, including my wife.
That might be a good time to talk a little bit more about...
Okay. Okay.
We're back on after short break. Dr. Aslan, I want to...
Just mention that, on this occasion, so your wife is in jail.
And tell me about your wife in the ways that matter to this very forceful commitment that she would have
and display in so many ways. And maybe you can broaden from there to reflect a little bit about...
Obviously at that time in those years, there was a pretty sharp split in gender roles.
And that might lead us sometimes to overlook the contributions of one of them.
And I'm interested in your perspectives on her, specifically in women's generally.
First about my wife, who's very, very smart,
she also had a way of getting you to do things that maybe you knew you weren't going to do.
When I say at that every major decision that I made, I attribute it to her.
And the marriage, having the children, going from Des Moines to Flint and Flint to Georgia,
to get involved in the civil rights activity, I'm saying that she...
If she had not been right there with me, I'm certain I would not have done it.
I do believe we had a vision, a shared vision, and how does that happen?
I don't think anybody knows, but few of us are fortunate enough to have a mate that you can share a vision with.
She made a lot of sacrifices to get me through medical school, because I was not one of Meens.
When we got married, we stayed with her mother.
And her mother was not a lady of Meens, she was a lady who was abandoned by her husband and left for children.
And my wife, the oldest, the eldest of the four, became the father, if you would, of her three siblings.
So, she grew up in an environment where she had to assume a lot of adult responsibilities before she was even 17 or 18 years old.
So, when I say that when she saw Me, what she saw in Me, I don't know.
But she saw something in Me that I did not see in myself, because there were those occasions when I would in despair, say, there's no way I'm ever going to get out of college.
Get an medical school and become a doctor.
And every time I would appear to be in despair, she would be the one to come along and say, you can do it.
And I'll be with you. You can do it.
So, she literally gave up everything, but peace and comfort and tranquility she had on the home in Atlanta.
When we went out to Des Moines, I went out first, saying something like, well, let me get situated in school.
I cannot afford. I don't have any money. We had $600 who I was named, tuition was $600.
So, she was going to stay with her mother in Atlanta.
And I was going to go back to visit at Thanksgiving, maybe Christmas, maybe spring break, maybe summer.
But the lady that I stayed with in a rooming house, Ms. Reeves, I never forget her, Ms. Reeves, Lola Reeves, a wonderful woman also.
She saw me pacing the floor at night and couldn't concentrate, couldn't sit still.
And she said to her neighbors and her family, he's never going to make a two medical school without his family.
So, she converted this one room into three petitions, she said that.
This is your living room, this is your dining room, and this is your kitchen, this is just one big room.
She said, you got to have your family here.
So, she helped me to bring my family up.
And one of my family got there, all of a sudden, my grades went out. She said, I was smiling.
I was able to get two or three jobs.
And it was just the fact that she was there, encouraging me, not ready to abandon me because I had this cock-a-mimmy idea about being a doctor.
And she was just patient, long suffering.
She understood me better than I understood myself and above all, whatever stupid cock-a-mimmy idea came up with, she would support it.
And if it was the wrong idea, she would somehow figure out a way to get me to change it.
So, she was ready to go to Flint with me.
She had been teaching some in Des Moines and she went to Flint and immediately got a job teaching in elementary school.
And so, I married, not just a wife, I married really an experienced mother who had the function as a mother and a father for her siblings.
And she used to say, you act like you're not even listening to me, but you realize after a while, what I'm telling you is the right thing and you do it.
And she said, you stubborn like me and I, you never wanted me to, that a woman is right.
But she says, I always know when I've gotten through to you and made you understand because you would do it.
You wouldn't admit it, but you would do it.
So, she was a pillar. She was a pillar.
How did you feel when she was arrested?
I was devastated.
I was devastated because I had no idea where she was, what they were going to do to her for treatment she was getting.
They put her out in Lee County.
I had never been there. I had no idea.
It was like a Lee County farm, prison farm.
And now I'm with my children, three children, because I've been four by then, the young fourth.
I had it not been for my in-laws. I called them in-laws once removed.
My brother married a lady from Birmingham, Alabama, whose sister married John Chatwell,
who was the director of music at Albany State College.
So when my wife was in jail and I didn't know what to do, I would not stay at home because the clan was having their meeting regularly.
It was the Chatwells, Richard Dean Chatwell and John Chatwell, who says,
we'll take care of your children. Got that?
You go ahead and do what you have to do.
It gave me some comfort to know that my children were well taken care of by John and Richard Dean Chatwell.
So for several days, I didn't see my wife.
I have no communication. I couldn't visit her. I didn't know where.
I was living in a different place every night, but Chatwell was taking care of the family.
That's very interesting.
So I had read where you had written in another place that of course you felt fear,
but not to the extent of paralysis or paranoia.
And that's important.
You can be afraid and not be paralyzed.
But it was necessary for you to take precautions to that level.
That's how pressing the danger was.
It was very interesting.
The Ku Klux Klan had a reputation for murder lynchings,
made him a la teo.
That's the work of the clan doing that kind of stuff.
So I was fully aware of that, but not to the point where I was paralyzed.
In other words, was I going on emotion?
Was I going on nerves?
Yes.
There were those times when I was going strictly on nerves and emotions.
Not intellect would have said, run away from this.
You don't have to take this. You're a doctor.
You got a license in Michigan. You can go back and practice.
No, I couldn't leave. I could not emotionally leave.
Let's talk about the arrests and negotiations with the city.
Well, let's go to when we took the petition.
All the petition said was we took it to the mail.
A point about racial committed to study the problems of segregation and discrimination.
Albany.
I gave it to the mayor myself, Aissa Kelly, who I say was, in my opinion,
had a tendency toward being a liberal.
He took it to the city council.
They were to have their regular city council meeting.
I think I've gone to Monday night.
I went to the city council meeting to get the results.
I had just come back over and wake in vacation and we were to send a committee.
Nobody in the committee showed up with me.
I was in the city council chambers and they went throughout the agenda and said nothing about our petition.
I got up in the chambers and said, Mr. Mayor, what about our petition?
I didn't hear anything about it.
He said we met in the executive session before the open meeting and decided there are no common grounds for agreement period.
The newspaper, the next day, Albany Hill reported, black doctor demands the end of segregation immediately and stormed out of the chambers.
City council chambers.
He published me in the newspaper next day.
And your address?
My address.
I started getting phone calls with threatening calls.
You can just imagine the kind of calls I was getting.
Did you know James Gray, the publisher of it?
From a distance I knew that he was a rabbet segregationist who ironically made a complete turnaround after I left.
And actually he became a business partner for a black doctor who came to town to go over my practice.
So it's amazing how once you take that yoke of segregation and discrimination over some white people, they become real people.
And they put aside their racist attitudes.
And Gray was one of those.
Gray was more of a business person than he was a racist.
And when he had an opportunity to capitalize on this side, he gave up his, he gave him a grand membership because he was an opportunity to be a business man.
Dr. Gordon.
Dr. Gordon became a business partner of Gray.
Carl Gordon.
They had a radio station together, they did some things and news paper together.
Other business Carl Gordon is dead now, but they became business partners.
How about the, let's talk about the kind of famous and much discussed moment when Dr. King takes bail on the presumption that the city will come through with some concessions and an honor for coming.
But on the, on that fateful day that you mentioned when King and I locked arms, abandoned my wife or directly behind us.
And this was the march where we had over 1000 people.
And we were marching down through Harlem, the main street from downtown, from, from, from the Harlem downtown.
They had called in the international guard, the national guard, the line in the streets of Albany with ready arm.
They had their guns.
You got to presume they were loaded, they were there.
One of the guardsmen stepped in front of me, marching, I would together, and say, you will stop this march now and raise up his gun.
I said to him, if you hit anybody in this line, hit me first, hit me first.
He took the gun down and stepped aside and we marched on down.
All of us got arrested.
Martin, Ralph and I were put in the same jail cell.
It is coincidental that Martin was scheduled to go and meet the press.
I said, my wife out to these brick of the year, but he was scheduled to go and meet the press.
And the, who was the moderator for me to press?
Lawrence Bevac was one who kept calling.
Lawrence Bevac, he kept calling the jail, calling the chief of police, Larry Pritchett, saying that Martin Luther King has got to come out of jail because he's to be on program tomorrow morning.
And Martin would say, I am not coming out of jail until these people read us sit down and talk.
And that was what it was all about. He wouldn't come out.
But then Martin said, being on meet the press is too important.
We've got to get the message out.
It's too important of a venue to get the message out.
So one of us has to go on that program.
I didn't have that kind of experience.
We drew straws. We've seen the jail sale and drew straws. I drew the short straw. And Martin says, you're going to meet the press.
You're going to meet the press.
Just like that.
We left about that some years later. Just like that.
We drew straws to see who would come out of jail to go and meet the press.
He said, when you had to get a hosepawn and get on an airplane and fly to the outside.
And you drew the short straw.
And Clarence Jones, who's a lawyer for MLT,
was the one who also met me in New York.
And that night I was up most of that being briefed.
The transcript of Meet the Press is in that book you just got.
What was your reaction as events would unfold and you'd have this reversal with the city?
On what you thought was something forthcoming in terms of some concessions.
When we, we'll move our rest of it again.
And this time in America's.
And they took us out of jail Monday morning and took us into court.
There were three blikes.
I believe Chapman, Cochran.
And a guy who was the local manager of Pilgrim Insurance Company.
And I might think of his name, but three blikes and three whites.
The whites were what?
A member of City Council.
And two others who I do not know who they were.
But anyway, these six people met behind closed doors.
And that was the verbal agreement made that we will meet your demands for the by-risk account.
A point met a by-risk committee.
And we will study the issues of segregation and discrimination in the city facilities.
Verbal.
They came out and Hallowell say, will there be a joint press conference if not a written document?
There was no written document.
Hallowell, of course, being the African-American term.
Don Hallowell, Martin, Martin Luther King said, we need a written document,
a written statement for the press.
At the very least, a press conference ensay it to the press.
They did not do either one.
Hallowell was a fine lawyer.
But he was more willing to accept them at their word that they would do that.
That he did not insist on putting it right in all having the press conference.
Martin and I were sitting next together in the courtroom and he says, I don't like this.
I'm sorry, I don't really like this.
But everybody was out of jail.
They signed what they called straw bonds.
But none of them were ever called back.
We were called back.
Abinathy King and I were called back for trial.
And of course, it was like a kangaroo court because when you go into the courtroom,
they judge already had the decision already written out.
And with a prosecutor attorney and the defense attorney's, but finished making that presentation,
he said, oh, here's my decision.
But they reneged on everything they said in that conference.
Now, it was reported that Martin Luther King failed in Albany because he did not do that.
Because he did not get anything.
However, one by one, they closed every public facility.
Library, parks, swimming pool, bus, lunch, count us, everything was closed.
What did we get out of Albany?
Yes.
Go ahead.
All right, go ahead.
All right.
Sure.
There's also the, you know, in the summer, 62.
When he comes back from that sentencing hall, he came in the CLC.
They want to see if they can't reintegrate the movement and push forward.
He brings staff to Albany.
He is arrested again.
And this time, there's actually, but in front of that, there's the hostel, frankly,
the hostel local federal judge.
J. Robert Elliott.
Exactly.
Robert Elliott.
I know.
He issues an injunction, I mean, further protest.
And there's the question in July, four days, just you should have Dr. King ignore or appear to that injunction.
We appealed and went to Atlanta before Judge Tuffle, Albert Tuffle.
And we were represented there, not just by Ternikin and Hollywood, but that's where Constance
Motley came.
Constance Motley.
And of course, the state was represented by the best that the state had to offer because
they brought lawyers in from Emory, from the first of Georgia.
And they cited case after case after case where we were breaking the laws and Constance
Motley without benefit of a single note stood up there and refuted every one of the cases
that cited and would say.
And if Ternikin from the University of Georgia had looked at how this was appealed and
next year it was reversed.
I mean she was amazing.
She just, and Albert Tuffle could do nothing but sit there in wonder.
She had never seen a black female lawyer.
That's smart.
And of course.
Karatiska King would later write that she thought that the quote was, that the failure
to ignore the injunction of the head was quote, that the factor that broke the backbone
of the movement in that moment, in that possible moment.
Was that your idea?
The thing that broke the back of it was the reneging on the part of the city for what
was agreed on.
In other words, we've all elated because we had come to the agreement, we got what we
asked for.
But then one by one, they closed all the facilities.
So yeah, you've got it.
But what did it mean?
It's like I won a 757 airplane and don't know how to fly a kite.
So it was a failure in that we did not get anything tangible out of it.
But what we got out of it though was the change in the attitudes and the perceptions.
White people had come to believe and I really think they believed it sincerely.
Black folks like it this way.
They are satisfying at being servants.
So the attitudes change because the perception change.
No, they don't like this.
And look what they did.
They rose up against us.
So maybe we have to look at them differently.
Black folks of course found courage in this new way to change the system and do it non-violently.
And so now they have made a determination.
You know we can change this so we're not going to take it anymore.
That was enough.
When the attitudes were changed and the perceptions were changed, that was the end of segregation
and discrimination as it was known prior to that time.
No, I'm very much agree.
I think that all of the people that go back up, we're back out of the same.
I think Albany was part of a long unfolding process that involved struggling many places
and it was instrumental in the local ways you mentioned.
In what it showed by way of inspiration, what it showed by way of model and tactics and
strategy and mass action, but there's no question.
How are you feeling by late summer of 62?
It's a lot of stress and strain.
I was literally exhausted.
At one point I was exhausted to the point where my wife again, she said you had to go away
and get some rest.
I was emotional and high, but physically I was deteriorating.
So she took me from Albany, took me over to Tuskegee.
I was a veteran.
Took me to the Veterans House Bill to make sure that I was physically alright.
I had checked around a couple of days and then she took me to her grandfather's home in
Silicaga.
He was a minister and I needed him for that spiritual revitalization.
So between those two in a week, I was ready to go back into battle, but I needed that.
I needed the assurance that physically I'm alright, but also needed that emotional strength.
Now I am not a religious fanatic.
Let me say that.
I'm not a religious fanatic, but I do believe that if they divine plan, I do feel as though
it was meant to be that I would wind up in Albany, Georgia, leading a civil movement.
Otherwise how did I marry this lady that put me with Martin Luther King?
I don't wind up going to Montgomery Falls places and meet Abanatha.
I mean, these things, in my opinion, just don't happen.
Now whether you believe in God or Maui or Allah or whoever, I do believe that everyone
has a purpose and everyone has a purpose in life.
And as much as you try to ignore it, you can't.
Tell me about, you mentioned that very interesting fact that afterwards you would develop something
in relationship with good terms with Lord Krishna.
A few years after the man, I went back down to all of the two or three years later when
things were beginning to settle down now.
No more demonstrations, no more arrests, no court hearings.
I was down there for something and I made what a policeman said was an illegal term.
And he said, I'm going to give you a ticket for what?
He said, you made illegal money.
So no, I didn't.
You give me the argument.
Yeah, I didn't do that.
You go in the jail.
All right, take me to jail.
So he took me to jail and who was in jail?
She printed.
I was being booked and she printed, heard me from his office.
He said, is that Doc Anderson out there?
Yeah.
Come into my office.
What's he, what you resting for?
He made illegal terms.
He said, give me that ticket.
He said, you'll never rest him in this town for illegal turning.
He'll have to have a demonstration down here.
But then we were on friendly terms.
The next time we got together was when eyes on the priors being filmed in Atlanta,
several years later, he heard that I was coming.
I knew he was coming because the producers had contacted all of us who had been
active in the Albina movement.
He got there, he had a me and he ordered to find a way I was staying and he literally
met me at the hotel.
Can we have dinner together?
My wife and his wife, the four of us, when I had dinner together and we relived those days
in Albini.
Thereafter, he visited me in Detroit because he would go up to Michigan State every once
and a while for some police stuff and I would go down to North Carolina, high point, North
Carolina.
We exchanged cards regularly.
We became good friends up until his death.
So the civil right movement emancipated some white folks and he's an example of how,
because he was basically a decent man as was Kelly, but trapped.
So you think it's interesting.
So looking at that span of years after through the 70s and 80s, you think that you think that
Laurie Pritchett could become a different person?
Or I should say his views about race had been fundamentally changed.
Oh, absolutely, but one of them waited a minute.
I said, I think basically, fundamentally, he was the decent man.
He was not a racist.
That was not him.
He had been placed in a position where he had to do what the City Council said.
If he had been free to do what he wanted to do, he bucked the City Council when he refused
to let his policeman perpetrate any violence against the people because ball-conner set the
example that this is the last thing you want to do, beat all these people up with all
the cameras of the world.
Because in Albini, literally, reporters of all of the world came to Albini and he said,
that's the last thing I want is this to go all over the world that we policemen beat
up people like they'd do in South Africa.
So he didn't work that.
So all he needed was the opportunity to get out of that.
And if A.C.
Kelly had lived, I believe he would have been the same way.
I was in Albini a month or a go.
Well, you were there for one of the events, but I was down there for SNCC also, their anniversary.
I went down there with a lady by the name of Rhea Hyle.
Rhea Hyle.
She's happy to be chairman of the board of one of the Detroit Medical Center hospitals.
Needless to say, she's white.
We went down there to Albini together.
We went to everything together.
There was barely a second look.
Albini has been desegregated to the point where it's as though it always has been this
way.
The federal court building is named after CB King.
The mayor, really Adams, is black.
Sheriff, black, former chief of police, black.
We went out to true through restaurants while we were down there and I had to call that
attention.
Honey, you look around here and every table where you see a group, every one to black, I
say, this would never have been 50 years ago.
So ask me, was it worth it?
Was it worth it?
Then the crowning experience of this trip was to go back to America's Georgia, the
Wingo Hotel.
If you ever get a chance to go to Wingo Hotel, it was an old aristocratic hotel where Jimic
Carter stayed, where Al Capone stayed.
I was there at Bellhop.
I did some other things that might have been somewhat illegal, but whatever the customer
wanted, I got it as a Bellhop.
I was 13 years old.
That was a pin-out suite there.
I could never have imagined staying in that pin-out suite as a guest.
I went there with this lady of German descent and stayed in the pin-out suite.
Was it worth it that I could do that freely now?
It was worth it.
Did your children, how did your children talk to you over the years about their recollection
with that experience?
Two of the three of them were old enough to realize what was going on and they wanted
to get in it because they were high school kids.
If you read the transcript from Meet the Press, I was chastised by Kielpatrick.
You get children out there.
It's their citizens also.
High school kids were in the marches going to jail and really for them it was fun.
It was.
They were laughing and talking and singing all the time and the sheriff would come in and
say, yeah, stop all that singing over here.
They would just ignore and go and sing in it.
So what are you going to do?
You know, electrocuted them.
Just be going to sing.
So my older two children wanted to go to jail.
My wife was in jail.
I was sleeping in different places every night and I just couldn't handle that.
That was too much.
That's when John and Richard Dean chat well said, we'll take care of the kids.
They wanted to be a part of it.
Now, they have been back to Albany this year.
They take tremendous pride in the Albany Civil Rights Institute because they say the
first thing we see when we walk in there is the quote from my father.
Any final thoughts?
I produce it.
I say I produce it.
I am the one who organizes this visiting minority faculty series at Michigan State
University.
It's been going on for 12 years.
During the month of February, black history month, every Thursday I bring in a distinguished
primarily African American scholars from civil rights era, primarily.
Some are brought in who are not African American like Tom Hayden and some that are more
contemporary like Charles Adams and who else have had contemporary.
But anyway, I was brought in the boy from down in Georgia that was there with Nick
Charles-Sharad.
She had a little bit of controversy that she got into with the President of the administration.
I brought her up there because she symbolizes the resistance that we had when people were
not being treated right.
In other words, she was doing the right thing and somehow another she got characterizes
or she was characterizes doing the wrong thing against white folks.
Anyway, I brought her up.
I am very proud of the fact that I have been able to bring them for 12 years now distinguished
African American scholars starting with my friend in New York, Wyatt T. Walker, who was
just outstanding.
I brought people like Juanita Ebenethi.
All she had to do was just tell the story how she lived at her house was barmed.
Now, her husband's property was taken away and now he died ignominiously.
And I brought up people like Joe Lowry, who was the, if you were the grandfather of the
movement.
I brought Bernie Stranson up twice.
I brought Duret the cotton.
These are the people that made the history.
And what I have said to myself and others in Michigan State is it's one thing to read
about it.
It's another thing to actually talk to the people who lived it.
It's sort of like the parallel I draw about Jesus Christ who came down off the cross and
there was doubt and Thomas put your finger in the womb where the spear was.
And I tell these people, Michigan State, come and talk to the people that went to jail,
the people whose houses were barmed, the people who had put out a job, come and see them.
These were real people.
This is not fiction.
I'm very grateful and it's a real honor and a privilege.
Your own time.
Thank you, Dr. Anderson.
What a pleasure.
Thank you.
You're very welcome.
This has been a presentation of the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum
of African American History and Culture.